make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video I want to be dangerous right
I want to have a discussion about Iron
Man versus Prince Zuko from from Avatar
now this is not really gonna be like a
like a physical fight between the two if
you guys like seeing characters they get
into like physical fights like physical
fight versus battles I have those on
patreon you'll find a link down in the
description
um this is more of a discussion on who
had the better story arc I will say that
I think a fight between Zuko and Iron
Man would be interesting but it depends
on on where we're talking about right
like if we're talking about
Zuko between the time period of the end
of the avatar series and the start a
legend Decor assuming that he was able
to actually bend lightning as opposed to
just redirecting it then if he can
control electricity like a lot of
firebenders can do then he can control
he can create EMPs right and there goes
Iron Man's suit unless Ironman is going
with those EMP protected suits which I'm
not really sure he has because they all
seem to run on some form of electricity
I will say this I think a fight that
would be hilarious would be tuff versus
Iron Man right that fight would be 5
seconds long right i immense like I'm
gonna defeat your top and Toph is like
uh-huh and they're just like crushes him
in his own suit it'd be hilarious right
at that fight would be so fast but but
for real official right get kind of
getting into this discussion
um these characters are intriguing to me
right and and the reason why is and
they're really the reason why I chose
this is because I Amman is a character
that I think a lot of people enjoy and
they like and Zuko is a character that
people who are fans of avatar are
fiercely protective about right now they
won't hear a word against him and it's
interesting when it comes to these
things so I kind of went to kick things
off with with Zuko but I want to talk
about Zuko for a second you know when
when you're talking about this character
and the funny thing is that within the
first season or so Zuko was a character
where he was there and it became obvious
his mission was to like track down and
catch any right and he was doing it for
like the honor and the glory of the Fire
Nation but as you began to get more
involved with his character you began to
learn that the the real desire of Zuko
is to prove himself to his dad right to
prove himself is like you know I'm
worthy of being the new king of the fire
Kingdom or like you can rely on me you
know trying to get his dad's approval
that was a huge focal point for his
character and and you look at different
episodes right you look at like the
awakening you look at the Winter
Solstice episode 1 episode 2 you look at
you look at Zuko alone which a lot of
a lot of fans of Avatar champion is one
of the greatest episodes of the series
if not the absolute best but you look at
these story arcs and you see these huge
shifts and these huge changes when at
the relationship between Zuko and Iroh
right and so in the beginning Zuko was
just hardcore why he was just this
hardcore guy who by all standards of
measurement was a dick right and and as
you get through that one of the funny
things is is his pursuit of Honor in his
pursuit of like I have to show that I'm
worthy of this is really sort of
countered by the fact that Aang is
really flying by the seat of his pants
right like he is he's an airbender he
has no idea what he's doing right I mean
like you're the new avatar man good luck
dude hopefully your friends can get you
through it and that was basically it
but as you go through that you know you
see Aang just kind of getting into
scenarios these fights with with with
with Zuko and where you do see these
moments where you can like champion Aang
and be like yeah man he's got these
small little bursts just like he has a
lot of power and you can do some crazy
cool things a lot of it is in a lot of
ways making Zuko look like a fool and
that makes him even more and more
frustrated right but the reality of this
is that as the show continues on and as
the show you know basically goes from
you know one episode to another episode
and one season to another season you
begin to learn that there's a lot more
to Zuko than what's going on and one of
the coolest indications of this comes
with us is encounter with Iroh right
with his uncle Iroh where he starts
talking to him and IRA really kind of
says you have to figure out who you are
man you can't live your life by somebody
else's standards and that's basically
what Zuko was doing right he was living
his whole life based on his father's
standards or his sister standards or the
overall fire nation standards right he
wasn't really living his life based on
what Zuko wanted to do and and the
reality was a Zuko didn't know what he
wanted to do because he'd lived his
whole life trying to seek the approval
of his father after his mother was gone
and that's what led into these small
little moments here and there right like
you know I will bring in the idea of
saying like this life that you live one
you only live at once and two you have
to make it mean something and if it's
going to mean something make sure it's
something that you wholeheartedly
believe if there's a part of you that
doesn't believe in the Fire Nation then
just have you to explore them and it's
time for you to find out where that's
coming from you know and then you get
these small little flashbacks while you
kind of go into the story of Zuko alone
you get these small little flashbacks
words it's Zuko's flashback to when he
was a child and you learned that the
reason
Zuko is is you know really more
emotional than you would you were
initially led to believe is because of
the moments with his mom right where his
father was pard and he was fierce his
mom had a far more gentler hand right
she was more kind and caring than his
father was and and that kind of
tenderness led to this sort of emotional
aspect of Zuko and you end up learning
that when it came to his emotional side
that he was repressed right but being
out of the fire nation and being out
there in the world you end up finding
that Zuko is far more emotional and far
more complex more than that he has to
come face to face with the consequences
of not just his actions but the actions
of the fire Kingdom and this is a
perfect example this is shown perfectly
when he's in Doug when he is up being
taken in by that family in the earth
Kingdom and them not knowing who he is
not knowing that he's a firebender not
knowing that he's the Prince of the Fire
Nation not knowing any of that stuff
they'd taken then they welcomed him in
right and he starts to kind of come to
this realization that people are not
inherently bad right people don't need
to be controlled and all that kind of
stuff the way he was taught to believe
in the Fire Nation and he starts to come
to the Sun at this realization that
pretty much everything he knows about
humanity through the lens that he was
given from the Fire Nation it's
essentially wrong right and that people
are just trying to make their way in the
world and people are kind and people are
caring and that kind of a thing and it
sort of allows him to effectively let
his guard down and this all really comes
to a head when you get to the end of the
episode and basically Zuko has to reveal
the fact that he is the Prince of the
Fire Nation they turn on him like that
right it's crazy right in the blink of
an eye they're like no you're part of
the Fire Nation get out and they kick
him out a little kid the thought he was
awesome it's just like I hate you right
there's just this this such extreme
animosity and hatred for the fire
kingdom you know in earth Kingdom itself
and various other communities that Zuko
has to come to this realization that in
reality he is seen as the bad guy right
and so now the mission is no longer
about I have to capture the avatar to
gain my honor and to prove my you know
prove my worth to my dad now it's not
only I need to figure out who I am where
I'm going what I'm about I need to prove
that I can be a good guy but I also need
to change the image of the Fire Nation
right the evolution of his character is
not done over the span of a single
season right it's not like Zuko B goes
from being a villain to a good guy in
like one season it takes place over the
course of the entire show right and one
that one of the coolest
moments with this is that when he ends
up getting to the point where he tries
to side with the with the avatar with
the avatar group right whether it was
with Aang's team that initially he's
rebuked by everybody except for Toph and
toughs like nope she goes to vouch for
him and says like this guy can do us
good we need a fire truck a fire vendor
to teach aang had it been fire and Zuko
has been trying to redeem himself right
and this pursuit of redemption combined
with past mistakes his life in the Fire
Nation betraying Iroh different things
like that but it all kind of comes to a
head with the fact that he is in effect
a good guy now you know and being part
of that group that goes to war with his
own Fire Nation you know and basically
says like you guys have become the bad
guys you guys are the enemy now you're
not good guys you're not bringing the
world to a better place
sure like Dobby no war and conflict and
turmoil but because you've taken away
everybody's freedoms and liberties and
you made the world a worse place overall
you know kind of adopting that ideology
and then going to war with the avatar
against his against his family was a
huge moment right so you see this total
like this perfect 180 between how and
how Zuko was presented to us versus what
he is at the end of the show and that's
kind of the cool thing is even when he
was first introduced you knew there was
something a little more there right and
like anybody who was a fan watching the
show you kind of had to you wanted to
scratch below the surface and see what
was there and finally you know we
ultimately ended up getting it and so
his development was was incredible it's
one of the reasons why a lot of people
say that Zuko is one of the greatest
literary characters of all time
right he went from being introduced as a
straight-up villain to becoming an
antihero to becoming a hero like all
over the course of a singular show that
combined with the emotional aspect right
him crying different things like that
we've just really sort of expanded on
the complexity of him and so from here
I'm going to switch over to Iron Man
right you know Iron Man Tony Stark is is
he's an interesting character in his own
right right I mean you know we're we're
Zuko has a lot of complexity insofar as
like his emotional state his backstory
following that journey Ironman has a lot
of complexity and what we've learned
over the years and what we've seen his
character experience both in the comics
and in the movies right so kind of
looking at the comic book counterpart to
him looking at his kind of book version
he was pretty straightforward in the
early days and a lot of that was because
of the way the Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
wrote comics well you know Stan Lee
wrote comics in the sense of he would
they were designed to be more
lighthearted and kind of a break away
from reality
from the from the struggles of the world
like the cold war that fear that kind of
went on different things like that it
was sort of a break away from all that
impending nuclear disaster and it was
kind of like here's an escape that would
let you leave the world behind and kind
of just go and enjoy comics without that
kind of a thing
and so when a man was first introduced
most of all you guys know the story
right he was based on a dare that in the
age of anti anti industrialism that Tony
Stark could create a character who was
himself an industrialist and people
would love it well you guys know that
you guys know that whole story and so
when stark was introduced in the comics
you know we kind of got his sort of
turnabout in the sense of him becoming a
tried and true superhero and one issue
at his and his original appearance right
and and for the most part the comics
followed the movies almost identically
the only real difference there is the
comics took place during Vietnam movie
took place in the Middle East right but
you end up finding out of course Tony
being a weapons manufacturer that his
weapons had been used for various
purposes and not all of them were good a
lot of them were nefarious it's the
nature of weapons and and the results of
this is that he was ultimately taken
prisoner and then ended up meeting a guy
named yo Henson and and the truth is
that we're I'm sorry ho yinsen rather
and the truth is that much like Pyro's
encounter with Zuko ho yinsen was kind
of like you have to learn there's
something greater than yourself here but
like your pursuit of whatever this is
money or power or women fame all of the
above right like that's not the end-all
be-all and when the time comes when you
die and you look back on your life do
you want to see a life pursued with
superficial things or do you want to see
a life that was pursued and meant
something right and so this ended up
leading to Tony Stark effectively
turning over a new leaf and becoming a
good guy now this goes into the the post
you know stark industrialist era and
goes into him becoming a new hero
becoming a hero in general right so the
the new era of Tony Stark and the truth
is as much as I love comics there isn't
a whole lot going there right I mean
there's a few arcs here in there for
example like demon in a bottle the idea
that iron man's alcoholism was
essentially catching up to him and
really came to a head in that story in
the sense that he was basically eroding
and taking away and ruining everything
about his life that he loved and so he
had to find a way to get that in check
on stories like armor Wars where his
technology is his start tight start tech
was being taken for the character of
Iron Man as a whole the idea of James
James Rhodes replacing Tony Stark
there were some cool moments that went
on there
I think in the modern era there's a lot
more interesting stories right the
secret origin of Tony Stark by Karen
Gillan will you learn that Tony's not
the biological son of Howard and Maria
instead that person is or no and that
Tony was adopted you get into Iron Man
international by Brian Michael Bendis
you end up learning that he tracks down
and locates his biological mom who's
still a part of his comic book story
which is currently being written by Dan
Slott you you see all these these these
kind of changes and these these cool
moments and you could just see Tony
Stark as just a tried and true dick
right during a Tom Taylor's superior
Ironman run where he uses the extremest
technology as a means to give people the
ability to look beautiful in the city of
San Francisco for one day and then
following that day they have to pay $99
per day in order to continue using the
app and the city descends into madness
right the the app becomes like a drug
and people just want to go back to being
beautiful again right so people are
attacking each other and robbing each
other or doing whatever they can order
to get that money to pay pay that app
for the day are you going like mad
fractions five nightmares right these
things where you learn Tony Stark's true
you have five real nightmares that are
out there the extremest story itself you
have a lot of really great moments there
but the truth is that in terms of the
progression of Tony there's only ever a
few landmarks stories right demon in a
bottle we already mentioned that Civil
War by Mark Miller and the the included
tie-ins with the Ironman Ironman comic
itself where he reveals to the world
like he basically stands up to the world
and says I'm an alcoholic one of the
first real moments in comics where he
effectively addresses it on a broad
scale you know these are these are cool
and interesting moments and death of
happy hogan Pepper Potts leaving him but
the reality of this and the reason why I
give this victory to Zuko is because you
don't really see stark progress in the
same way that Zuko did right there is
the element of stark trying to prove
himself being as good or better than his
father but that's not the overarching
art but that's not the overarching theme
right Tony Stark like a lot of other
kind of like heroes out there is
designed to find a particular villain
and when that story's done you move on
to the next story that's especially
prominent in the modern age when a lot
of writers like Chris Claremont and and
Roy Thomas and and you know bill Mantlo
and Peter David are a thing of the past
and so you don't really see these super
complex stories that focuses just as
much on the fighting as they do on the
to development itself that's kind of
gone away uh instead it's just kind of
like here's six issues where iron man
fights a guy and then he wins and here's
the next six issue where he fights
another guy enemy wins and it just kind
of goes on you know with that with
regards to that that kind of repeating
pattern but but nonetheless you know
it's 20 soccer is a great character he's
super intriguing he's very interesting I
will say that I think Tony Stark and the
movies is far more developed and far
more interesting and more complex than
that he ever really was in the comics
and a lot of that's because of the fact
that the movie the the 10 years we saw
this this Marvel Cinematic Universe
going on it was an effective story of
Tony Stark is really what it was right
the idea that he goes from being a
weapons manufacturer seeing what impact
it has on the world the fact that that
stark you know Stark Industries is
considered to be a negative company
essentially like people are only a part
of it because of the money it generates
but in terms of its moral perception and
it's in its moral place in the world
it's the bad guy basically and and going
from that abandoning that becoming a
superhero trying to do some good and
then making mistakes along the way right
the idea of trying to harness artificial
intelligence lady the creation of Ultron
different things like that right and
then ultimately making the call to
sacrifice his own life for the purpose
of saving the world there's literally
saving the universe there's a lot of
development there right so he was far
more developed in the in the movies and
I think he ever really was in the comics
but still in comparison to someone like
Zuko whose journey we follow whose
journey is so exceedingly emotional and
whose father we can replace with our own
fathers or a particular event a
particular scenario those things are
kind of interchangeable
it makes Zuko relatable in a way that
Tony Stark just isn't right it just it
makes him relatable it makes him
tangible because depending on where
you're coming from in your life and what
experiences you've had
you could be Zuko right like you could
be that guy right this idea that you're
trying to prove yourself for a
particular cause or to a particular
person whatever that happens to be your
family your friends somebody that you
know your employer or what have you and
and along the way you end up having
either somebody come into your life or
circumstances that are introduced in
such a way that it changes your mindset
and forces you to accept that one you
don't know who you are you don't know
where you're going you don't know what
you want and you've been wasting your
time by not figuring that out and so you
do i Zuko did you effectively leave
everything behind you go on this journey
of self-discovery right and you learn
all these things about yourself
only to find that who you are hates who
you've been and so it's it's it's
awesome to kind of see that that that
sort of progression with his character
right and so again I give the victory to
Zuko here he's just far more complex
he's way more developed and an overall
he's probably one of the greatest
literary characters that that's ever
been created in terms of a person be go
starting out as a villain becoming an
antihero and then becoming a full-on
hero so that being said guys we're gonna
be this video to an end uh if you are
new here two comments explain and make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like now we'll catch you all later
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you